You should definitely speak two languages.
Partly because speaking another language makes
you think more rationally, but also because
sexy accents make people totally irrational.
Hola everyone, I’m Julian and willkomen,
bienvenue, welcome to DNews.
Before we start I want to pose to you a question.
Lets say I gave you 15 dollars and then started
flipping a coin.
Lets say you had the choice to bet a dollar
each time, and if you win you get a dollar
and 50 cents, but if you lose I take your
dollar.
How often would you bet?
It seems straightforward, but your answer
probably depends on where you’re from.
More specifically, it probably depends on
whether or not I asked you that question in
your native language.
The science says if you speak english, you
probably bet about 54% of the time.
But I know there’s a lot of you from outside
the U.S. because I get a lot of angry comments
every time I use the imperial system, and
if you’re from a non-english speaking country
you probably bet about 72% of the time.
Well you’re gonna hate this my fellow Americans,
but betting every time is the right choice.
Statistically speaking you’re almost definitely
going to be making money in the long term.
So why did native english speakers pick wrong
more often?
Well the current hypothesis is having to think
in a foreign language requires more cognitive
power, and by having to think it through more
thoroughly, you’re more likely to make a
rational decision.
This experiment was first done by researchers
from the University of Chicago in 2012.
It took place on 3 continents and participants
were english-speakers who had learned japanese,
french or spanish; and Koreans who had learned
english.
So it’s not like it’s just english speakers
who declined to bet more, it really does depend
if you’re asked to bet in your mother tongue.
The researchers extrapolated this information
to more common scenarios.
One researcher, Albert Costa, mused that maybe
this is why people switch to their native
language in a heated argument, and maybe that’s
also why they tend to say more hurtful things
they’re going to regret after the switch.
The researchers also didn’t believe that
the cognitive improvement is lessened with
proficiency, noting that when people understand
complex nuances of languages like idioms,
taboo words, and expressions of love, they
still react less emotionally.
This just adds another reason to the long,
long list of why being bilingual is awesome.
And yes the delayed onset of alzheimers is
rad, and being able to survive in a foreign
land is cool, but I’m telling you dude,
chicks dig accents.
So does being bilingual make you smarter or
does being smarter make you better at languages?
Trace and our guest Alice have the answer
to that over here.
And did you bet when I posed you that question?
Or have you learned a second language and
noticed a difference in how you think?
I’m always interested in hearing about stuff
like this because I grew up in America and
I’m just now getting the hang of speaking
the english talk.
So let us know in the comments and I’ll
see you next time on DNews